My mum is the best at catching the bus...
...'cause she's the best runner.
My mum's favorite thing to do is listen to the TV while she's sleeping.
The funniest thing my mum has ever said was that my brother has bushy eyebrows.
She can't dance.
If I had 100 pounds, I'll give her a trip to Disneyland.
She really wants to go there.
I'll buy my mum a real dinosaur so she can ride in there...
...and doesn't have to catch a bus.
On Mother's Day morning, I'm gonna make breakfast for my mum.
I'm gonna see if there's a chili competition because she loves chili.
Without her knowing, I'm gonna sign her in.
Mum, Happy Mother's Day!
Guess what I got you.
A chili contest!
You're doing a great job, mum.